اذا خطفت اجواء المونديال فاجات العالم
واسعدت العرب وصنع التاريخا رياضيا مستحقا
فوز السعوديه الاستثنائيه على الارجنتين
بهدفين مقابل هدف واحد في افتتاح منافسات
المجموعه الثالثه من مونديال كاس العالم
الذي يقام في قطر قلب مقاييس التوقعات
ورهانات فالاخضر نجح في ان يكون اول منتخب
اسيوي يهز شباك الارجنتين باكثر من هدف في
تاريخ كاس العالم الفيفا اعتبرت المباراه
واحده من اكبر المفاجات في تاريخ
المونديال ليونيل ميسي الذي يقود منتخب
التانجو الارجنتيني اقر بنفسه بالهزيمه
امام السعوديه وقال انها قاسيه جدا
دارنا اخضر
قلبنا اخضر
فالنا اخضر
كلنا الاخضر
[موسيقى]
درفه لا خبر
[تصفيق]
دربنا
[موسيقى]
عودتنا يا فخرنا لا خبر
نتابع مباشره من الدوحه مع مفرد العربيه
عبد المحسن الحربي عبد المحسن اهلا بك
معنا هل ما تزال اجواء الفرحه سائده بين
الجماهير السعوديه والعربيه كذلك
نعم صهيب بالفعل ليلى غير عاديه تعيشها
الدوحه اليوم بعد انتصار الاخضر التاريخي
امام الارجنتين في بدايه او في الساعه
الواحده من دور هذا اليوم بدات الاحتفالات
مبكرا حتى قبل همم انتهاء المباراه بدقائق
بعد ان خرجت بعض الجماهير لتحتفظ في
انتخارج الملعب استمرت الاحتفالات حتى هذا
الموقع في كورنيش الدوحه وهو موقع خالي من
السيارات
والمشاعر الجهات المنظمه هنا وضعت الاغاني
السعوديه الوطنيه بين فتره واخرى بالاضافه
الى تواجد همم البيت السعودي الذي هو همم
انظار كل المشجعين دي مختلف المنتخب
السعودي ربما في همم بين الجماهير
السعوديه يعني هناك الكثيرون الذين الغوا
رحلات العوده الى السعوديه للاستمرار في
الاحتفال هذه الليله في الدوحه
نعم صهيب وهنالك من قرر ان ياتي الى
الدوحه بعد نتيجه هذه المباراه الكثير من
المشجعين السعوديين تحمسوا للمسكوت اكثر
ناس هي ما بعد ان تصاعدت فرص المنتخب
السعودي بالتاخر لمراحل مقدمه من هذه
البطوله بعد فوزه على اقوى منتخب في هذه
المجموعه الارجنتين متبقي مبارتين ولكن
العدد الكبير من ال مشجعين السعودي
ولكن هي فرحه سعوديه اكيد بالاساس ولكن هي
فرحه عربيه يعني كل الوطن العربي كان
اليوم فرحا مع هذا الانجاز الكبير
السعوديه ما الذي رصدته كذلك بين المشجعين
والوفود الاخرى غير الوفد السعودي كذلك
بعد هذا النصر التاريخ
يعني احدث صهيب عن اجواء ما قبل المباراه
يوم الامس كان هنالك الكثير من التساؤلات
ايضا مشجعين المنتخب الارجنتيني كانوا
واثقين جدا من الانتصار كان هناك بعض
المناوشات المرحه بين الجمهور السعودي
والارجنتيني ومختلف المشجعين لكن اليوم
انقلب الحال الى ان
المشجعين مختلف المنتخبات اصبحوا ينظرون
الى المنتخب السعودي والجمهور السعودي
بشكل همم خاص بنظره مختلفه بعد تحقيق هذا
الاتصال الكبير الاجواء اختلفت بشكل همم
كبير المنتخب السعودي هو اول منتخب من 32
منتخب يحقق مفاجاه البطوله ناسيا من
المنتخبات التي همم لم تحقق انتصارات
كثيره في كاس العالم فبالتالي كل الانظار
اتجاهات الى الاخضر وجمهور السعوديه شهاده
الكثير من وسائل الاعلام الدو صهيب تبحث
عن الجمهور السعودي تجري لقاءات معهم
تسالهم عن توقعاتهم همم بعد هذا الانتصار
التاريخي بالاضافه الى همم ان احضر حظيه
بدعم اكبر الان من الجمهور العربي همم
الخليجي بعد هذه
بعد هذا الانتصار التاريخي توقعات ايضا
بان تكون مباراه هولندا المباراه القادمه
للمنتخب السعودي حضور اكبر قدوم اكبر هي
المشجعين السعوديين همم من السعوديه الى
الدوحه وهذا سؤال التالي لك عن المباراه
القادمه بعد هذا الانجاز التاريخي حدثنا
عن الفريق البطل عن همم المنتخب السعودي
الان بعد انجازه في ملعب لوسيل همم كيف
سيكون التحضيرات للمباراه القادمه
نعم بالرغم من ان هنالك اصابتين اليوم ااا
بالغه لنجوم الاخضر السعودي نتحدث عن سالم
الدوسري والشهراني في التالي تاكد غيابهم
عن المباراه القادمه الا ان الاخضر حقرا
الانتصار وقلب النتيجه دون هذان النجمين
الذين اخرجوا او عفوا سالم سلمان الفرج
فقط بينما الشهراني اصيب في اخر مباراه
بالتالي عمليه التحضير ستستمر خلال الايام
القادمه استعدادا لهذه المباراه الاخرى
وهي مباراه صعبه جدا ايضا همم على المنتخب
السعودي ولكن بعد هذه الانتصار التاريخي
توقعات اصبحت عاليه
الطموح اصبح اعلى بكثير لدى همم الجمهور
السعودي فبالتالي اصبحوا يطالبون همم
النجوم الاخضر السعودي بالنتيجه ايجابيه
في المباراه القادمه التي ستجرى بعد ايام
المنتخب السعودي دخل اليوم في الاستعداد
الى المباراه
دي ما في معسكري في الدوحه بالتالي همم
سيتم الاستعداد لهذه المباراه خلال الايام
القليله القادمه قبل هذه المباراه مع
هولندا وهي منتخب ااا قوي لديه واحد من
المعجون حول العالم وهو ليفاندوسكي مهاجم
برشلونه فبالتالي سيكون ستكون مباراه صعبه
وليست اقل صعوبه من الارجنتين لكن التفاؤل
والطموح اصبح عالي جدا لدى المشجعين سواء
كان السعوديين او حتى العرب الذين اعذروا
المنتخب السعودي اليوم في الدوحه نعم عبد
المحسن همم مبروك همم مبروك للسعوديه
مبروك لكل همم العرب وكل التوفيق اذا في
همم المباراه المقبله والمباريات المقبله
كذلك للمنتخب السعودي في كاس العالم
مباشره من الدوحه مفيد العربيه عبد المحسن
الحربي شكرا جزيلا لك
والاحتفالات بفوز الاخضر السعودي على
الارجنتين عامه شوارع المملكه وكذلك
الشوارع العربيه من مصر والعراق ودول اخرى
عبر المواطنون عن فرحتهم بهذا الفوز نشاهد
بصراحه للشعب السعودي وبحريه على اللعب
اللعب النهارده وياريت ااا يفضل كده طول
المونديال يعني هم شرفوا العرب النهارده
اداء يعني منهم اا الشوط الثاني عملوا شغل
عالي قوي عرب واحنا كلنا عرب ونحب
السعوديه ونقول الف مبروك الف مبروك وكلهم
رجاله والحارس راجل والمدرب 100 100 ان
شاء الله الماتش الجاي هيفوزوا كلنا معهم
وهندعي لهم من قلبنا باذن الله بصراحه
المنتخب السعودي يشرف العرب كله اداء
ممتاز همم الدوسري وكل احبابه وعملوا ماتش
ممتاز احرج والارجنتين في اول ماتش لهم
وان شاء الله احنا كمصريين في ظهر
السعوديه احنا كلنا اخوه
تستاهل تكون في القمه
تستاهل تكون من اول شيء
اعداء المنتخب السعودي ويفوت على
الارجنتين
شو يعني مصر بكره القدم
السعودي والمنتخب السعودي والشعب العربي
مو بس الشعب السعودي الان نقدمه وداع حلو
ويستاهلون الفوز انهن الشعب السعودي طبعا
اليوم ابداعه فول الجولتشي عويس صلوات على
محمد
الى السعوديه
نبارك لمحمد سليمان اليوم مريدي نبارك